رغم ان في موسكو الا ان الجيش الروسي متهم
بمواصله استهداف قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا
تحضيرا لشتاء قاسم قادما للطرفين
المتحاربين غداه الضربات التي تسببت في
اوسع انقطاعات للتيار في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه منذ نشوب الحرب استمر انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي عن اكثر من ثلثي كياف
اضافه لغياب امدادات المياه العاصمه كانت
من بين الاهداف الرئيسيه لموجه الهجمات
الاخيره على منشات الطاقه ما دفع السلطات
لقطع الخدمه عن عده مناطقها لترشيد
استهلاك الطاقه واجراء الاصلاحات اللازمه
مع اقتراب الشتاء رئيس بلديه
كافكو قال انها الفنيين يعملون لاعاده
التيار باسرع ما يمكن لكنه اوضح ان اعادته
تعتمد الى حد كبير على توازن الطاقه في
اجمالي الشبكه الوطنيه داعيا السكان الى
تخزين ما يكفي من الماء والطعام
والامدادات لفصل الشتاء
[موسيقى]
اذن اربعه قتلى جراء قصف روسيه على مدينه
خيرسون وفقا لحاكم خرسان الاوكرانيه هذه
المدينه التي انسحب منها الروس مؤخرا
روسيا تستعد لتجميد الاوكرانيين لكن لم
يعد بامكانها الاعتماد على الشتاء بحسب
مجله بوليتيكو اضافه المجله ان روسيا تريد
استعاده ذكريات التاريخ عندما ساعدها
الشتاء على ايقاف جيشين نابليون هتلر ومن
المفترض ان يكون الشتاء صديقا جيدا للقوه
الروسيه لكن لم يكن الحال كذلك دائما
بنسبه لروسيا فالشتاء لم يقف بجانبهم عام
1940 عندما قلب الفنلنديون الطاوله عليهم
خلال حربهم الشتويه انا ذاك انه قد هو
المحللون العسكريون توقعوا لاشهر ان
الشتاء سيحدث فجوه في القتال على الجبهات
الاماميه الاوكرانيه وان الطاقه الروسيه
تقضيء الضعافي معنويات المدنيين
الاوكرانيين من خلال قطع الكهرباء
والتدفئه فيما يسعى الاوكرانيون للاستفاده
من التجنيد الروسي سيء التجهيز وفي حين
انه من المتوقع عموما ان تتباطا وتيره
القتال الا ان القتال لم يتوقف في المناطق
الشرقيه من دنيتك ولجانسك على الرغم من
درجات الحراره المتدنيه
قوله ان المعارك تدور ليلا ونهارا بغض
النظر عن الطقس مضيفا ان القتال بالقرب من
بخموط يتارجح بين كر وفر من الجانبين كما
اوضحت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان الخطه
تهدف الى مواصله الضغط خلال الشتاء وربما
الاستفاده من هذا الفصل ومحاوله الوصول
الى شبه جزيره القرم
الاوكرانيون يريدون البناء على الزخم
العسكري الذي حققوه حققوه مؤخرا بالتقدمات
التي حققوها حول خارقيف وخيرسون ما يجعل
القرن في مرمى صواريخهم
[موسيقى]
عن معهد دراسه الحرب الامريكي ان الشتاء
مع تجمد التضاريس سيساعد كلا الجانبين على
المناوره لكن من المحتمل ان يكون للتقص
البارد اثر على القوات الروسيه
ومعداتها الرئه وذكر المعهد بل ذكر بفشل
التقدم الروسي نحو كياف في الشتاء الماضي
توقع المعهد ان يعمد الروس الى بناء قوات
على الحدود البلا روسيه شمال كياف مره
اخرى في محاوله لكسب او لسحب القوات
الاوكرانيه بالاحرى بعيدا عن خط المواجهه
في الجنوب والشرق تقييمه معهد دراسه الحرب
اشار الى انه من المرجح ان يكون الشتاء
بجانب الاوكرانيين بسبب نقص او انعدام
الخبره لدى المجندين ضمن التعبئه الجزئيه
الاخيره بينما تعمل موسكو على تدريب
قواتها وتجهيزها بعد ما نشر مجندون على
موقع تلغرام مقاطع لظروف السيئه التي
يواجهونها من بين امور اخرى ورد ان القوه
الروسيه بدات في تلقي ستره وقيه من الرصاص
اضافه الى خوذات ايرانيه الصنع لكن من غير
المرجح ان تضاهي جوده الملابس والعتاد
الغربي المقدم لاوكرانيا على سبيل المثال
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ارسال مئه
وخمسه
و900.000 طقم للشتاء اذا مئه وخمسه وتسعين
الفن من الاطقم للشتاء كما يقوم شركاء
غربيون اخرون بتوريد مولدات محموله وخيام
تكفي لمئتين الف جندي اوكراني
الفصل الاخير في الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا لم يكتب بعد لكن مشرعا روسيا
لديه تصور لمشهد ختامي وان طال الزمن
تحقيق العداله بمفردها على حد قوله وان
توصل الرئيس الاوكراني مع دائرته الى حبل
المشنقه
قد تلاحق الرئيس الاوكراني مع دائرته
الداخليه مدى الحياه وخلال لقاء
التلفزيوني قال النائب النازل انسكي
والمحيطين به ربما تكون لديهم منازل سريه
في مكان من العالم لكن يجب ان تطالهم
يدرسيه
مطلوب لدى الشرطه البريطانيه لقتله جاسوسا
سابقا في لندن عام 2006 هو الضابط السابق
في المخابرات الروسيه اليكساندر لتبانكو
باستخدامي ماده البولونيوم المشعه تحدثنا
كثيرا انا ذاك عن هذا الموضوع تذكرون خلص
تحقيق البريطانيه عام 2016 الى ان القتل
ربما تمت الموافقه عليه من قبل رئيس
المخابرات الروسيه انا ذاك نيكولاي
باتروسيف مع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتل